voilà pour l'histoire et on comprend
mieux en voyant l'intensité de la crise
pourquoi il a fallu 50 ans un peu plus
de 50 ans d'ailleurs à ces deux pays
cuba et les etats unis pour commencer à
se retrouver au moins une table de
négociation vous savez que ça a commencé
la semaine dernière à la havane on va
parler de tout ça et de la portée de
l'accord historique annoncé enfin plus
exactement du rapprochement annoncé
mi-décembre avec nos invités avec le
réalisateur de documentaires sylvain
d'emile mais aussi la politologue
janette habel spécialiste de cuba à
l'institut des hautes études de
l'amérique latine l'écrivain et
journaliste cubain racault beau match
ouvert j'ai essayé de réviser les cours
d'espagnol pour vous très fameux vous
êtes exilé en france depuis 50 ans où il
peint à peu près vous aviez neuf ans
lorsque vous avez quitté la havane
l'historien thomas snégaroff spécialiste
des états unis à l'institut des
relations internationales et
stratégiques et plus françois clemenceau
rédacteur en chef étranger au journal du
dimanche longtemps correspondant
d'europe 1 aux états unis vous publiez
un hillary clinton de a à z aux éditions
du rocher hillary clinton fait partie
d'ailleurs de cette génération
d'américains qui sont les enfants de
cette crise on en parlait tout à l'heure
c'est tout à fait passionnant sylvain
d'emile d'abord moi je suis frappé par
les documents sonores qu'on entend dans
votre documentaire sont des documents
absolument exceptionnel que vous avez
retrouvé été ou en fin de compte kennedy
avait à partir de quelques mois voire en
avant à la crise avec demandé à la cia
de place et de métaux found ans
à la maison blanche un dans son bureau
et un sou la salle du conseil et il
était le seul à être au courant de cette
installation sans doute le directeur de
la cia parce que dans quand on épluche
un petit peu l'ensemble de
toutes ces eps ces enregistrements
secrets en quelque sorte eh bien on
s'aperçoit que le directeur de la cia
parle toujours très doucement et a
souvent inaudible
elle doit être quand même au courant les
autres même son frère ne sont pas au
courant il ya juste sa secrétaire qui
qui sait pas ce que c'est elle en fin de
compte qui change les bandes qui est là
pour pour pour livrer les escamoter mais
bon ce par sc bon ensuite alors elles
sont classées elles sont oui elles sont
classées parce qu'en fin de compte le
successeur johnson va s'apercevoir qu'il
ya des magnétophones est lui même va les
utiliser donc après on va avoir toute
une succession de président de la
république deux présidents américains
qui vont en quelque sorte utiliser un
petit peu cela pour quoi là ça devient
plus
plus complexe à déterminer la version
officielle c'était de dire
kennedy était un homme moderne il avait
pas de temps à perdre à prendre des
notes donc il enregistrait tout pour
faire ses mémoires
officielle ne peut pas exclure qu'ils
espionnaient on veut arrêter le chef de
l'armée faille s'espionner lui-même
d'une certaine manière pour garder des
preuves de ce qui se passait ou de ce
qui se disait sont sans doute c'est en
tout cas ils les installe après la
sphère de la baie des cochons ou
quelques départements ils sont
totalement la cia à cuba c'est ça qui a
échoué il a pris la responsabilité de de
cet échec on l'avait mis un peu devant
le fait accompli il en a toujours
énormément voulu à l'armée et à la cia
de ne pas avoir réussi en qu'auxerre
cette tentative d'ailleurs après il va
demander à son frère de préparer de
nouvelles tentatives parce que
franchement il leur
est donc sage et juste après qu'ils
commencent à installer ces métaux phone
donc on sent qu'il a aussi besoin après
d'avoir des preuves pour dire oui vous
voyez il ya des choses qui se passent
j'en suis responsable je les assume
parce que finalement il assume beaucoup
de choses quand on entend ces eps et
puis en revanche les choses dont il
n'est pas responsable il voudra
peut-être que au regard de l'histoire
est bien on sache exactement quelle fut
la vérité qu'il poussait éventuellement
aller plus loin on l'a bien entendu il
ya un certain nombre de témoignages sur
ce qui s'est passé de l'intérieur on
allait quoi la biographie
l'autobiographie khrouchtchev j'imagine
expurgés il ya eu deux zéro licenciement
il ya eu deux versions il ya une auto
biographique qui était officielle
jusqu'en 1992 la traduction française de
94 je crois pour la version non expurgée
de par le kgb et c'est là où on
notamment dans cette toute cette version
non expurgée on apprend pas mal de
choses sur les relations très tendues
qui existaient à l'époque de la crise
des missiles entre castro et
khrouchtchev parce que bon il faut il
faut imaginer castro qui est comment
dire dans son île enfermé avec quand
même une menace de débarquement une
menace de bombardements atomiques sur la
tête ils sont que toute l'histoire lui
échappe que toutes les négociations se
font entre cannes et des écoutes chef et
donc à partir d'un certain moment et ben
il pète un iep est un câble
littéralement idées théoriques les ondes
et les lions
furibonde aa khrouchtchev en disant il
faut déclencher la guerre atomique et
franchement aux alentours du 27 il ya eu
des choses et des zones de tension qui
ont vraiment failli aboutir à un
déclenchement armée raul castro va
mettre quand même une batterie de
missiles devant guantanamo
avec lady l'idée de tout de suite
éradiquer la base américaine qui était
quand même toujours là
comment dire
qu'à ce trophée boire l'ambassadeur
américain comme un trou pour que celui
ci accepte de rapprocher les ogives des
deux têtes nucléaires des missiles de
manière à pouvoir les envoyer
et il ya eu le fameux incident avec
l'avion u2 à la direction qui a été
abattu je disais il ya le bio de
l'autobiographie de coach of ya celle de
robert kennedy vous en parlait
d'ailleurs dans votre film ce qui est
frappant dans les enregistrements qu'on
entend dans votre documentaire c'est
qu'on découvre un kennedy je vais pas
dire dépassé par les événements mais
bousculé on a toute la gamme en fin de
compte on voit au début il l'a c'est
très étonnant parce que quand là vous
avez que de quelques petits extraits
mais quand on les écoute dans la
continuité il ya l'équivalent de plus de
700 pages de transcriptions par rapport
rien que par rapport à cette crise donc
on a quand même une masse de documents à
celle ci n'en et on voit la voie qui
change et c'est très très impressionnant
cercle où débute une voix blanche il est
hyper calme ont l'impression que
qu'il essaye de voir tout ce qui se
passe tout ce qui risque de se passer on
voit qu'il est dans l'analyse il écoute
beaucoup les gens qui sont autour de lui
il pose énormément de questions et puis
peu à peu on s'aperçoit que l'homme
politique sans la responsabilité qui lui
incombe et sa voix change et à devient
de plus en plus ferme et à la fin même
et pique des colères et ses très rares
dans les enregistrements secrets sur
toute la période jusqu'à la mort de
kennedy
je crois qu'il ya deux colère qui ont
été faites dont une qui a qui est
présente dans le documentaire que je
révèle à ce moment là quand on finit de
regarder ce documentaire on se pose une
question toute simple c'était du bluff
c'était un grand bluff ou on est
vraiment passés à deux doigts d'un
anéantissement là ce n'était pas un
grand bluff du tout je vais vous en
parler d'autant plus que moi petit
j'étais présente sur place le 22 23 24
octobre on va jusqu'à la fin octobre
j'avais un père citoyens américains et
dans l'inconscience personne n'était au
courant de ce qui se passait donc j'ai
pris l'avion de la panaméricaine la
veille de la crise d'octobre mais
accompagnée mais en tous les cas ce
n'est pas du bluff du tout par contre ce
qui est un coup de bluff et de poker
c'est ce que le coach of et c'est ce qui
me frappe je trouve votre documentaire
très intéressant parce que ça malgré
tout on se rencontre c'est un coup de
poker invraisemblable il se fait traiter
d'ailleurs d'aventuré avant d'être
destitué et je trouve que le
qualificatif est assez bien vu et c'est
vrai que tout ça passe par dessus la
tête des cubains est ce qui explique les
réactions du beurre cubain dans cette
affaire c'est que ils n'ont participé à
aucune des décisions à partir du moment
où le scandale éclate alors ce qui est
frappant vous le dites pas d'un
documentaire mais andré fontaine le site
fidel castro aussi dit qu'il y a eu un
agent soviétique qui a informé les
américains et qu'en fait les photos
viennent après c'est parce qu'il ya eu
une information d'un agent soviétique
une tome que leur extraordinaire oui
aller se rhabiller
donc et cela dit même la décision
initiale ça vous le montrer dans le
court métrage très très bien aussi c'est
khrouchtchev qui prend la décision pour
protéger parce qu'il ya l'opération
hmongs qui se prépare une nouvelle
invasion à cuba ctc coach qui prend la
décision et et castro et cubaines sont
très réticents au début pendant cet
hiver et en plus il commet une deuxième
erreur qui est soulignée par les autres
commentateurs c'est qu'il veut que cette
histoire soit secrète ce que vous dites
aussi dans le film ce qui est
complètement stupide que tout fan de
quoi il s'agit ça pouvait bien soit pas
être secret et le souvenir que j'en ai
un qui n'est pas très politique je peux
vous dire mais j'ai le souvenir d'une
chose d'une anecdote on voyait passer
moi j'étais accompagné dimanche à are
you enfin de espèce de truc immense dans
les rues et fidel castro dans ses
discours et oui parce que nous allons
nous défendre contre les américains à
nous avons des lance-roquettes des
khatchkars et c'est à des mitrailleuses
etc etc et comme ce peuple cubain est
tellement vif il appelait ses immenses
ce qu'on voit là sur les images il les
appelait les et ses terrains etc etc
était difficile c'était les missiles
c'est pour vous dire que ce n'était pas
secret non plus à ce moment là vous avez
déjà quitté cuba donc vous pouvez
commencer s'arrêter enfants mais on
était complètement inconscient
d'ailleurs heureusement on peut
la décision finale n'était pas entre les
mains de file car tonini du terrain
parce que si si ça avait été le cas
c'était la guerre nucléaire à tous les
coups j'aimerais juste citer une phrase
d'une lettre de fidel castro à coacher
fils disait ceci est une c'est un
langage un peu alambiqué mais on peut le
comprendre que facilement disais si les
impérialistes envahissent cuba dans le
but de l'occuper le danger d'une
politique aussi agressive et si grand
pour l'humanité qu'après cela l'union
soviétique ne devrait jamais laisser se
créer une situation où les impérialistes
pourrait frapper contre elle le premier
coup d'une guerre nucléaire autrement
quatre autres cadres ont décoré les mais
elle ne tienne n'était pas beaucoup
mieux alors lui disais c'est l'exemple
et au nom d'un peuple qui est prêts à
s'immoler par l'atome par la tombe pour
que ces cendres servent de ciment à des
sociétés nouvelles
il prenait le peuple cubain comme un
peuple capable et joyeux et tout à fait
décidée à s'immoler à à l'époque il y
avait bien conscience totalement étant
enfant les gens criaient et dansé dans
les rues en
chantonnant quelque chose que ça disait
ceci nikita mariquita look et c'est
l'annoncé qui tu es en d'autres termes
nikita nikitin take it off et petit pb
est ce qu'on offre on ne l'enlève pas ce
qu'on offre c'était les missiles
nucléaires vous voyez le degré
d'irresponsabilité
et il n'y a rien qui peut justifier ça
c'est évidemment la haine quand ça vient
ça vient de là rochon inédit et castro
mais
parce que c'est un débat comment marié
depuis les mêmes ce qui est en jeu quand
même il faut le comprendre c'est la
souveraineté nationale d'un tout petit
pays qui a été envahi je ne suis pas
d'accord avec votre interprétation de la
lettre est autorisée mais oui merci
c'est ce que du physique oui on peut
faire on peut faire de l'explication de
texte à partir de cette lettre mais en
fait ce qu'il y a derrière cette
décision que je leur répète n'a pas été
choisi par tunnels castro et neil
décider par eux c'est que se prépare une
deuxième intervention après la baie des
cochons qui s'appelle l'opération mango
c'est une deuxième avion qui est
préparée par le gouvernement américain
est en fait l'acceptation on peut
discuter on est dans un contexte
totalement différent aujourd'hui en face
ce qui est en jeu c'est une force de
dissuasion c'est comme ça et sai on a
les textes et vous le montrez bien des
rôles dans le film une force de
dissuasion pour empêcher cette invasion
bon voilà c'est ça qui est temps dans
celles ci sont je veux dire il ya une
guerre au moins des mots et une guerre
totale déclarée par kennedy à castro à
l'époque oui mais bien sûr on peut on
peut résumer la faire à une relation
entre cuba et les etats-unis mais faut
pas non plus oublier l'urss et à mon
avis moi ce qui se joue aussi c'est un
duel entre deux hommes qui sont kennedy
et khrouchtchev et il a il ya un truc
qui à mon avis est très fort et qu'on
voit un peu dans le film et c'est pas
que c'est difficile à mettre en images
parce que fortement une belle image mais
peut-être en remontant un peu plus tôt
on aurait pu le voir en jean en juin
1961 à vienne c'est leur première
rencontre
et kennedy y va avec l'idée de vous
montrer à khrouchtchev qui il est
réellement parce qu'il supporte pas le
fait que khrouchtchev le prennent pour
un gamin et là ils n'arrêtent pas de
dire oui j'en ai marre de ce type qui
arrête pas de dire ce nouveau président
américain j'ai hâte de le voir il a
l'âge de mon fils il veut lui montrer et
ses trois jours catastrophique et en
bobby raconte que à l'issue de ces trois
jours kennedy revient aux états unis et
il dit à son frère il est pire que papa
khrouchtchev marc humilié et m'a utilisé
et ce qui se joue c'est à dire que paris
allait venir ce qui se joue à mon avis
n'a pas été assez dur est-ce qu'il soit
joué dix était quelqu un ancien
ambassadeur absolument s qui se joue un
an et demi plus tard c'est un peu le
match retour et même si effectivement on
sent la crainte qui monte
progressivement dans la voix de kennedy
il veut pas céder il ya beaucoup
d'ailleurs de métaphore du western on ne
fait pas tomber larmes le premier qui
tire le plus heureux et qui cligne de
l'oeil et sans essai permanent et je
pense qu'ils se jouent aussi quelque
chose entre ces deux hommes et c'est
frappant ou parler de blog tout à
l'heure c'est rageant de voir à quel
point on était proche pour répondre à
votre question de la guerre atomique
mais aussi en raison de l'amateurisme
des uns et des autres ou plutôt deux
problématiques individuelles et à
l'ambassadeur en urss vous montrer dans
le film aux nations unies il découvre il
découvre ce qui se passe il ya une
première lettre écrite par khrouchtchev
qui arrive aux états unis plus une
deuxième un peu alors là travailler par
par la bureaucratie qui est différente
on répond à laquelle on sait pas qui
fait quoi kennedy il est face à un tout
petit nombre de personnes l'excom et
c'est son frère qui n'a aucune
légitimité qui ministre de la justice je
pense qu'il va faire là qui vient lui
expliquer peut-être qu'ils essaient de
modérer les temps là que les actes eux
man loves comportement des militaires
qui veulent aller plus loin enfin on est
quand même un truc très très atypique
très étonnant on ne sert en ça que je
crois que c'est une crise comme ça elle
appartient vraiment au passé et je pense
que vous avez raison tout cas la
personnalité castro l'essentiel mais le
rapport entre cannes et des gros chat
est une des clés de résultats
cinquante deux ans plus tard les états
unis et cuba décide de se parler à
nouveau officiellement c'était le 17
décembre dernier 17 heures précises
heure de paris tornos semences à mal car
nous nous sommes tous américains
challenge round alors le changement est
dur dans l'envié dans la vie des nations
unies le changement est encore plus
difficile quand elle parle pas de
histoire sur ses épaules
nous faisons ces changements parce que
c'est ce qu'il fallait faire tout doux
cette décision du président obama mérite
le respect et la reconnaissance de notre
peuple
je veux remercier et saluer le soutien
du vatican et particulièrement du pape
françois
d'un françois l'autre françois
clemenceau cinquante deux ans quand même
ouais 52 ans ils sont pas parlé il ya eu
un blocus américain celui qui est
décrétée par clélie en 62 il tient
encore 52 ans plus tard oui c'est plus
le même le premier blocus et un blocus
militaire le deuxième blocus qui se met
en place après et un blocus économique
et commerciale afin extrêmement puissant
et sévère et un américain va pas à cuba
comme ça il va pas d'ailleurs au fur et
à mesure des années à partir des années
80 le régime s'est légèrement entrouvert
légèrement libéralisé et d'année en
année ça il ya eu des ouvertures quand
même qui ont été faites mais c'est vrai
que il ya encore une dizaine d'années si
vous vouliez en tant qu'américain vous
rendre à cuba vous étiez obligés de
passer par un certain nombre
d'autorisations fallait passer par le
mexique ou par le canada n'y avait pas
de ligne directe pour pouvoir partir des
états-unis directement à la havane bien
évidemment c'est une situation
absolument surréalistes cinquante ans
plus tard oui parce que la crise a
marqué les esprits à ce point vous dites
c'est frappant chez hillary clinton par
exemple oui parce que pour tout ce qui
est ici d'ailleurs la milice des
affaires étrangères américaine la
secrétaire d'état comme mondiaux aux
états unis oui lui à gérer ça et elle
elle fait partie de cette génération
d'américains qui ont connu cette période
vraiment de pic de crise au milieu des
années 60 elle l est de l est de 47 donc
elle raconte tout ça dans ses mémoires
elle dit moi je me rappelle l'époque où
on nous apprenait à nous réfugier sous
les tables à faire les exercices d'
alerte parce qu'il y avait la crainte du
péril nucléaire parce que c'était la
guerre froide parce que notre professeur
nous disait que il valait mieux vivre
mort que vivre rouge et elle est
complètement influencé par cette cette
idéologie de l'époque ses parents eux
mêmes sont très conservateurs et vivent
dans le culte the lower etc et donc je
pense que lorsqu'elle devient secrétaire
d'état de de barack obama elle ne peut
pas effacer ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle a
été ce qu'elle a reçu comme éducation et
en même temps
elle fait partie de ceux qui conseillent
à obama de lâcher du lest c'est à dire
que dans ses mémoires diplomatique à la
fin de son mandat au département d'état
elle explique que la situation n'est
plus tenable que le statu quo ne peut
plus durer qu il faut changer de régime
donc elle même est à l'origine d'un tout
petit nombre d'évolutions mais
aujourd'hui lorsque obama dit on va
rétablir les relations diplomatiques
avec cuba elle est à 100% derrière et si
jamais elle est élue dans deux ans ce
sera probablement à elle que reviendra
la tâche de vraiment normaliser devaient
voir raul castro pourquoi ou à les
imaginer ça vous imaginez oui sans doute
de l'un de l'autre bien évidemment ça
vous a ému quand même ce moment ragoût
match ouvert ou pas du tout que c'est
une question de
goût que je sois ému par le
rapprochement diplomatique entre obama
et charles castro et
lorsqu'au maman laisse de côté toute
aspiration à la liberté dit crûment
qu'il laisse tomber l'opposition qu'il
laisse tomber l'exil tout le monde a
paru sur une trahison pour moi c'est non
il n'ya pas d'autre mot où il y en a
beaucoup d'autres en réalité mais
hillary clinton elle aurait peut-être
pas fait même si elle l'avait fait au
moment d'une génération différente obama
beaucoup moins de connaissances du cube
il y a dit répété que en fait l'huile
était née après et la baie des cochons
et justement il veut
s'inscrire dans une nouvelle période qui
n'est pas celle de
de cet affrontement historique en
affrontements extrêmement violents et
qui fait partie de la mémoire à la fois
des cubains mais beaucoup moins un
peut-être parce que dit on c'est pas
tellement transmis mais peut-être
beaucoup d américains et certainement
des russes aujourd'hui et au marron avec
tout ça et il laisse il l'est et
ce régime
se développer à sa guise alors moi j'ai
trouvé que la déclaration conjointe ou
plutôt simultanée entre obama élu et
réélu président d'une grande puissance
démocratique et le dictateur folle car
trop en même temps c'était par moment
l'expression grotesque c'est à dire que
là il y à une
véritablement l'acceptation
l'acceptation de ce régime qu'il n'a
aucune légitimité réussi peut-être face
à alors obama mais ça parce que il a
expliqué je crois il a dit à mon avis il
sait déjà que les castro sont pas
éternels et il imagine ce que sera à
cuba après et moi j'ai l'impression que
les est arrivé en disant les états unis
ont pas envie d'avoir haïti à proximité
de leurs côtes ils n'ont pas envie
d'avoir un pays qui s'effondrerait avec
des flots de migrants avec un pays les
états unis qui doivent intervenir en
permanence pour stabiliser les choix qu
au delà au fond et c'est très important
ce que vous êtes en train de dire donc
je sais comment dire c'est un pari pour
l'avenir oui ça de la rive pour les la
réal qu'il suffisait de la realpolitik
ces deux là parce que on peut on peut
sauter sur notre chaise dire c'est
scandaleux mais en même temps les états
unis ont des relations cordiales avec
l'arabie saoudite on doit ces jours ci
avec des tapis dans le monde entier
chine qui sont pas plus en tout la chine
il y aura une exception cubaine je suis
en fait elle a été à la une elle a eu
cette exception pendant des années mais
ça n'a pas fonctionné et je crois que
les élus cuba dans la mentalité
américaine dans l'histoire politique
américaine cette lame c'est la mauvaise
conscience et on le voit encore en 1898
c'est l'acte de naissance de
l'impérialisme américain cuba au nom de
la liberté individuelle au nom de la
souveraineté pardon du droit des peuples
cubain à exister hors du de l'orbité
espagnols les américains vont intervenir
mais on le sait déjà à l'époque c'est
l'impérialisme puisque en 1901 trois ans
plus tard il impose amendement platt
faire que toute la diplomatie cubaine
elle est dans les mains des états unis
est en réalité dès l'origine il ya une
espèce de péché originel
de cuba qui est finalement que en
annonçant qu'on allait faire de cuba le
laboratoire de l'amérique aux américains
au sens beau du terme noble du terme à
savoir le droit des peuples à disposer
d'eux mêmes en fait qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé les etats-unis ont mis un premier
pied aux philippines et à cuba un pays
impérialiste sur ce continent et c'est
un peu ça qui est en train de se régler
aujourd'hui enfin en train de se régler
ou pas mais en tout cas c'est les
contradictions c'est cette place très
particulière qu'à cuba dans la mentalité
politique américaine et qui déchaîne
encore les passions aujourd'hui quelle
est la portée exacte de ce qui a été
annoncé elle est historique alors moi je
suis gelé concrètement qu'est-ce qu'il
ya de la place qu'il va y avoir un
ambassadeur des états unis oui ok bah
bah tout de même pas tout de suite parce
que ça dépend quand tu congrès sa
nomination elle ajouté juste je vais pas
répéter je suis d'accord avec ce que
vous avez dit sur le plan historique pas
d'accord avec vous et parce que ça on
love bien entendu mais j'avais bien que
cela représenterait libération nationale
est la souveraineté akbar vous l'avez
jamais compris mais voilà après quelles
que soient les défauts de cette
direction et de ce gouvernement pour
mais non ne vous bagarrer pas là dessus
ça c'est pas très important si j'ose
dire chacun s'exprimera s'est il
inquiété patrick c'est premièrement nous
sommes tous américains et obama
reconnaît que pendant 50 ans et demi
siècle sa politique la politique
américaine a échoué et ça c'est un
constat qu'il est rare d'ailleurs
d'entendre de la part d'un chef d'état
qu'est ce qui va se passer maintenant il
va y avoir des négociations longues il
va y avoir de négociation pas seulement
pour la reprise des relations
diplomatiques mais surtout pour voir
comment on abroge vont contourner
l'embargo commercial dont vous parlez
aux parents et lahoud blocus égouts dans
la corbeille de négociations il ya des
choses très compliquées parce que il ya
les nationalisations qui ont été
effectuées après la prise du pouvoir des
nationalisations qui concerne à la fois
des propriétés américaines que le
gouvernement cubain s'est dit prêt à
indemniser
mais des négociations qui concernent les
propriétés des cubains qui se sont
exilés à miami et celle ci le gouvernant
cuba a d'ores et déjà dit qu'il n'était
pas prêt à négocier sur ce plan-là
guantanamo bon pied quand même quelque
chose une base sur le territoire cubain
qui est dans une
utilité jozic totale parce que personne
n'y a aucun aucune date fixée aucun
terme fixé à l'occupation de cette base
il est à l'immigration les flux
migratoires c'est un long processus a
commencé ça que je comprendrais l'on
prétend on peut comparer à quoi a
tellement chaud aux accords de paix
israélo palestinien au moment où rabin
et arafat se serre la main à washington
oui en cas de rapprochement vers et
voulait rien n'est fait mais
symboliquement la main est tendue c'est
ça il faut qu'il faut considérer qu à un
moment si vous voulez il y arrive dans
l'histoire ou après s'être combattu
housse être ignorée des personnalités
très fortes décide de miser sur l'avenir
est effectivement de se voir de se
serrer la main de mettre à plat les
choses sur la table et de dire ok
maintenant on y va par le biais de la
négociation et non pas par le biais de
l'affrontement ou de la posture replier
sur soi-même c'est ça qui est en train
de se passer oui la difficulté c'est que
comme vous venez de l'exprimer c'est que
ça prendra probablement plus d'une
génération avant de se mettre en place
d'abord parce que on a beau dire le
président des états unis a beau être soi
disant l'homme le plus puissant de la
planète il ne l'est que lorsqu'il à un
congrès qui partage avec lui exactement
la même volonté les votes ça autrement
dit exactement c'est pas gagné c'est
absolument pas gagné dans la mesure où
le congrès d'aujourd'hui là qui vient de
prendre place depuis le début janvier
c'est un congrès dont les deux chambres
sont aux mains de ses opposants
donc ça repousse la question finalement
à 2016 avec une nouvelle élection
présidentielle et avec une une remise en
jeu d'une partie des sièges à la fois au
sénat et à la chambre des représentants
et on va voir comment précisément le
successeur ou la personne qui succédera
à obama c'est une femme arrivera à m
et c'est pour ça que c'est intéressant
parce que quand on parle de questions de
génération les américains obama hillary
clinton et d'autres savent très bien que
la jeune génération des cubains aux
états unis est derrière ce processus est
qu en fait même si c'est triste à dire
je suis d'accord avec vous pour leurs
parents leurs grands parents ceux qui
ont souffert bien sûr c'est compliqué et
que c'est difficile mais les jeunes
aujourd'hui veulent tourner la page oui
je voudrais qu'on je vais vous redonner
la parole parce que je veux bien
s'entendre là-dessus aussi voudrais
qu'on aille à la little habana c'est du
côté de miami où des dizaines de
milliers d'exilés cubains ont trouvé
refuge écoutez ce reportage et
réfléchissons
little havana à miami
c'est ici que des milliers de cubains
ont trouvé refuge après la prise de
pouvoir par fidel castro
je suis contre les communistes comme
obama
l'ouverture donne une chance au régime
en lui donnant un soutien économique ça
renforce le régime dans son oppression
contre le peuple cubain
mais si les exilés de longue date refuse
toute ouverture le ton est différent
chez ceux arrivés plus récemment yvette
tient un blog d'information sur cuba son
public la jeunesse cubaine qu'elle soit
sur l'île ou installé à miami
la confrontation n'a rien apporté je
pense que c'est une approche positive
d'autoriser les cubains à voyager à
venir aux etats-unis
s'il y a plus de contacts les gens à
cuba peuvent voir ce que c'est une
démocratie j'espère qu'un jour cela leur
donnera l'idée de construire un système
similaire
avec une levée de certaines restrictions
des cubains peuvent désormais se rendre
librement à l'étranger et revenir
ensuite à cuba mais pour ramon tant que
le régime reste en place un retour au
pays serait une trahison
des bruits courent si je devais rentrer
à cuba ce serait seulement avec une arme
à la main comme lors de la baie des
cochons un combat est la seule manière
d'éliminer le système
rpt ago goût machover z a co écrit et je
ne pense pas que ce soit avec des armes
à la main mais je ne rentrerai à cuba
que lorsque le système sera éliminé et
consomme castro a prévu jusqu'en 2018
pour lui 2018 pas 2016 et d'un autre
côté il y à une succession une
succession qui est en train de se
préparer et peut-être avec d'autres
personnes que la famille carton mais il
ya aussi la famille 4 qui en place
notamment par le fils et la fille de
raul castro longtemps pour voir ou qui
peuvent avoir un pouvoir considérable à
ce moment là qu'ils partagent une ligne
identique mais c'est toujours les droits
de l'homme écoutez sur la question des
droits de l'homme il ya eu depuis
l'accord depuis la déclaration conjointe
entre ans pour maman et forme car il ya
eu une recrudescence de la répression à
cuba considérables notamment il y à une
femme une artiste plasticienne qui
d'ailleurs a donné des cours beaux-arts
à paris qui s'appelle tania bruguera qui
a essayé de prendre les gens m'ont hélas
voulu installer at complètement insensé
un micro sur la place de la révolution
nous on appelle pas placer la révolution
l'appel place civique notre foi et il a
voulu installer ce micro il a été arrêté
trois fois ensuite relâché les autres
personnes qui voulaient s'exprimer ont
été arrêtés d'autres ont été obligés de
la répression alors du côté des états
unis on ne dit rien si quand même et
roberta jacobson celle qui mène les
négociations du côté des états unis elle
s'est aperçue en plus tard peut-être que
il y avait une dissidence à cuba et il a
reçu alors du côté que les américains le
savent bien les quotas compte trois
libérations prisonniers politiques
il n'y a pas non pendant
au niveau des délibérations qui était
qui était un des termes de l'accord
alors sur les 53 il y en avait déjà qui
étaient dehors il ya délibération qui
sont conditionnels c'est à dire si ces
gens et se remettent à faire de la
politique contre le gouvernement
castriste ils peuvent être remis en
prison et le régime a bougé ça n'a pas
bougé vos arguments mais est-ce qu'on
peut pas aussi envisager que les castro
donc vous détestez se sont maintenus au
pouvoir présider mais pourquoi est on
vraiment pourquoi mais bien non c'est
tout à fait légitime pour que les castro
se sont maintenus au pouvoir aussi en
raison de la politique américaine et que
précisément un peu vous cherchez un
modèle vous cherchez un modèle
historique est ce que finalement le
modèle de la fin de l'urss avec une
espèce d'ouverture dans un dialogue
constructif avec l'ouest n'a pas fait
bien plus pour faire tomber l'urss que
l'endiguement absolue du communicant
raul cas si ça peut être pas les accords
d'helsinki les accords d'helsinki qu'il
y a eu entre les états unis et l'union
soviétique prévoyez est quand même un
soutien à la dissidence il y avait un
soutenir la dissidence à il n'y a pas de
soutien la dissidence il l'a plutôt ce
que ce nom palin trahison sur la
question générationnelle j'aimerais bien
des maux suggérèrent sur la question
générationnelle effectivement les plus
anciens exilés on
donc une envie c'est que le régime
s'écroule aujourd'hui pas par les armes
à la main tout le monde au pratiquement
tout le monde adopte une attitude
pacifique à l'intérieur et à l'extérieur
de cuba non
parce que la violence et l'a amené à
cette horreur la violence
révolutionnaire et la violence contre
les lyonnais ont ils abouti à rien donc
on cherche d'autres formes d'autres
méthodes et pour pour véritablement
construire une société libre une société
démocratique
là dessus les vieux et les jeunes tout
le monde est d'accord là dessus du
moment où ils pourront s'exprimer
ils ne peuvent pas s'exprimer à
l'intérieur de cuba mais il s'exprime
d'une autre façon aussi les en fuyant ou
filles en liquidant votent avec leur
fille moi je me souviens les tubas
votent avec leurs pieds est une jolie
expression je la garde
la dérive un mort en exil qui s'appelait
juan accompagnement quelques années ce
qui me frappe quand on discute avec les
cubains exilés
c'est que certains détestent castro
beaucoup
et presqu'autant l'amérique est ce qu
autant les états unis oui parce que le
le si j'ose dire l'eldorado d'un cubains
exilés c'est pas une amérique à cuba
missionné parce que c'est l'histoire
cubaine c'est une histoire très
compliquée cette histoire cubaine ce
pays était le dernier en amérique latine
à conquérir son indépendance
ce pays a été
pratiquement il s'est établi une pseudo
république vous le rappeliez tout à
l'heure à partir de 1902 sous domination
américaine le rêve des présidents
américains c'était d'en faire le 51e
état et donc il ya une chose qui me
semble incontestable je comprends pas
qu'on ne comprennent pas ça il y a un
sentiment d'indépendance de souveraineté
à cuba de l'inité qui l'emportent sur
tout le reste et ce en coin soutenir
forcément raul castro a écrit mme je ne
vois pas qu'on soutienne d'abord
maintenant la situation est
effectivement beaucoup plus compliqué
mais pourquoi qu'on peut pensez vous que
le pape françois et l'arrière à l'an iv
lille et le rôle justement qu'elle
jouait le pape dans cette affaire est
très important parce que vous ne savez
pas sa peine est dit dans la presse mais
une partie des négociations a eu lieu au
vatican non au canada oui ça a été dit
mais l'autre partie a eu lieu au vatican
est donc une église à cuba oui bien sûr
il ya des prêtres qui est humaine avec
un cardinal qui a un rôle considérable
dans la négociation d'un régime
communiste avec des aiguilles à
contrôler et surveiller il a été
interdit pendant longtemps par exemple
parce que cette église catholique
maintenant a pignon sur rue le cardinal
ortega a joué un rôle majeur il y à une
hiérarchie catholique qui est divisé dès
hier mais dont une bonne partie a fait
pression pour la libération d'un certain
nombre de dissidents effectivement et
surtout pour la reprise des négociations
c'est une situation qui n'a rien à voir
avec la chine avec l'union soviétique et
je dois dire que finalement si on fait
le bilan un peu de ce qu'on a vu dans le
film 7 ce qui s'est passé avec l'union
soviétique et avec ces bureaucrates qui
étaient en partie stupide on voit bien
dans le fini les parties ça je trouve ça
excellent de voir comment kennedy lui à
des réunions collectives avec ses
conseillers comment même il sort d'une
salle pour les laisser décider et
comment krotov et les autres du site
toussaint la bna travail dans le film
c'est que beaucoup de chauffe est
congédié après la crise kennedy moeurs
l'idée est que ça ait pu avoir quelque
chose à voir c'est une possibilité mais
françois clemenceau on est dans une
vraie hypothèse quoi avec on y voit
toutes les théories conspirationnistes
qui ont circulé là dessus depuis 40 ans
ont montré leurs limites aussi mais vous
les trouvez pas cohérente
c'est la thèse nous avons une thèse à un
écrin que j'adore vous aimez sûrement
ellroy développe salles en mai à cannes
tablait dès raconte en fait la thèse
c'est quoi parce que ce que montrent pas
le film suffisamment mon avis et c'est
normal dans un cadre en deux minutes
c'est après parce que ce qui s'est passé
après la crise bien plus tard des mois
plus tard c'est le démantèlement des
fusées jupiter qui est en turquie et la
promesse par les américains peu tenue
d'accord de ne pas déstabiliser castro
or or ce qui présuppose la théorie du
complot c'est que les mafieux avait
porté au pouvoir john kelly dans 60 avec
la promesse qu'il renverserait fidel
castro et qu'il ainsi rang qui le
rendrait leur caddie nouveau bas à
partir du moment alors ça c'est pas beau
ça
c'est au moment où les mafieux
apprennent qu'ils ont été trahis par
kennedy puisque pour gagner la bataille
que j'évoquais tout à l'heure avec roach
et décide finalement être et bien
peut-être que les mafieux auraient
décidé de tuer kennedy qui les eaux qui
les en fait trailer mal rangé au rayon
sonic
c'est ce que je m'apprêtais à expliquer
ce qu on peut peut-être besoin de
conclure c'est que c'est lié à la fois
l'assassinât de kennedy et lit mais de
quelle manière on le sait pas apparaître
aussi les forces castris deux ailiers à
et la baie des cochons et à la crise des
missiles c'est tout de toute façon moi
je suis persuadé qu'on connaîtra jamais
la vérité on aura que des éléments mais
je vous mets ça m'intéressait que vous
l'évoquez que vous me donniez votre
votre vision de cette affaire là je
disais tout à l'heure contre chop up de
côté kennedy assassiné finalement il
restait un survivant et on l'a vu le
pointer le bout de son nez début janvier
à cuba
c'est fidel castro évidemment que qu'on
a vu réapparaître à la télévision
cubaine pour inaugurer une exposition
d'abord images devraient être appliquées
en tout cas à connaître leurs journaux
d'exilés cubains les annoncé mort est
annoncée en même temps qu'ils étaient en
train de creuser pour lui un mausolée
dans un des cimetières de la havane
c'était l'année dernière qu'il est
réapparu là il a juste fini une lettre à
au footballeur argentin diego maradona
dont on ne connaît pas le contenu et on
voit simplement il montre simplement de
la signature
de sens et penser aux voyages des bijoux
des dernières images convient de vous
montrer ma non les images il n'y a pas
eu d' images sont de fidèles il n'a
ignoré
nous on n'était pas sur cette idée là ma
question c'est la suivante est ce que
vous imaginez une seconde qu obama
aurait pu tendre la main comme il l'a
fait à raul castro à fidel castro est ce
que symboliquement c'était j'imaginais
d'une part samsung imaginables et
d'autre part je pense qu'ils ont il est
possible qu avant la fin de son mandat
il aille à cuba il est invité dans et
déjà il va rentrer outre et raul castro
et évaluer ce que la main au panama au
mois d'avril lors du sommet des
amériques on n'a pas parlé du rôle de
l'amérique latine dans ce rétablissement
des relations qui est très important le
peuple amérique latine mais oui et
risquait de se retrouver un sommet où
tous les chefs d'état vont être présents
au panama au mois d'avril et il risquait
de se retrouver devant la moitié des
chaises ville des présidents latino
américains et pas seulement de gauche y
compris conservateurs y compris le
président colombien qui avait dit qu'il
ne viendrait pas à ce sommet
traditionnel si cuba n'était pas invité
donc il va se retrouver avec raul castro
à la même table au mois d'avril mais ça
m'a fait ça pour une photo au sommet de
l'amérique latine oui c'est très
important et quand même adam c'est aussi
pour se rapprocher d'un est dans un
espace qui était quand même en train
d'échapper aux excès dont il a besoin
aussi écoliers évidemment le chiffre de
l'asie-pacifique est bien beau mais il a
aussi besoin de son centenaire la
violence traduit un mes premières votre
question je pensais je suis assez
d'accord avec vous un cerf que si fidel
castro mais j'attends de la vidéo buzz
je voyais qu'il y avait une hypothèse je
pense qu'effectivement fidel castro à
une telle image dans l'imagerie culturel
populaire américaine que ça aurait été
plus difficile à mon avis de se
rapprocher de lui plutôt que de raul
même si ça change rien d'un point de vue
politique mais d'un point de vue
symbolique fidel castro s'est quand même
celui qui a tenu tête à temps et en deux
présidents américains vous permettez
juste un petit commentaire raul castro
je pense que vous me démentirait pas à +
6 aux états unis que fidel castro a
écouté il était en instance de procès à
miami jusqu'à une époque récente ce qui
n'est pas vrai pour les américains
plus mauvaise réputation encore à cuba
parce que c'est l'homme de la répression
c'est l'homme qui a toujours il est
toujours été ministre des de la relient
déjà mes forces armées révolutionnaires
et puis la contrôler aussi les services
de sécurité mais castro c'est vrai il
n'a pas du tout d'image d'être logés
considérons qu'il n'a pas d'image
personne ne le connaît tandis que fisel
tu ne me connais le bal mais mais mais
le personnage solitaire et pour en
revenir à la crise des missiles c'est
lui même qui a négocié d'ailleurs
l'accord avec les soviétiques qui qu'ils
n'ont fait boire non pour qu'ils s'y là
on voit beaucoup à l'époque
soviétique ont fait boire non mais c'est
une certaine technique des soviétiques
et puis maire avons 4ème surtout bon ça
ne va pas entrer dans les choses entre
intimes surtout le whisky pas tellement
l'hôte bon mais et c'est lui qui est il
était d'une certaine façon conscient de
la folie de l'installation de ces
missiles nucléaires à cuba et donc il a
dû boire pour
pour signer il est toujours sous
l'influencé de son frère aujourd'hui
ils ne pensent plus rien s'est il déjà
depuis donc depuis l'année dernière son
frère aîné état dans un état senna n'a
rien dit sur le rapprochement elle pas
du tout aimé sur le rapprochement il n'a
pas accueilli les espions cubains qui
était en prison aux états unis et il n'y
pas par ici n'est pas apparu là c'est
qu'il est en mauvais état il est temps
de son mandat
un dernier mot sur ce que les cubains
peuvent en espérer
aujourd'hui c'est je crois que c'est 19
$ par mois le salaire moyen d'un pur
point de vue financier le les nouvelles
dispositions qui sont mis en oeuvre par
des executive order de la maison blanche
font en sorte qu'aujourd'hui les cubains
exilés aux etats unis vont pouvoir
envoyer quatre fois plus d'argent sur
leurs familles
installées à à cuba on peut détruire
c'est pas assez on peut trouver de
cubains aux états unis à peu près deux
millions un peu de millions doivent
envoyer jusqu'à 2000 euros chacun voilà
dont la moitié de la moitié vivent à
miami l'autre moitié dans le nord de la
côte est et notamment dans le new jersey
ça va être intéressant aussi de suivre
un peu comment les cubains des etats
unis vivent ce rapprochement au fur et à
mesure encore une fois vous avez
n'oubliez pas qu'ils jouent quand même
un rôle important sur le plan électoral
dans la politique américaine vous avez
trois sénateurs aujourd'hui qu'ils sont
d'origine cubaine au sénat sont trois
républicains l'un d'entre eux pourrait
se présenter à l'élection en 2016 ils
ont leurs parents ont tous émigré à
cette époque là dans l'est à la fin des
années 50 menendez les parents de rubio
les parents de tête cruz donc cette
histoire est quand même mais les
nouvelles histoires voilà exactement en
vous écoutant d'ailleurs tous les cas de
ce soit merci d'avoir été avec nous s'il
avoir éclairé de vos visions
contradictoires et c'est bien normal
vous pouvez évidemment continuer à
commenter cette émission sur notre mail
la semaine prochaine c'est claire
barsacq que vous retrouver pour un débat
sur les perturbateurs endocriniens les
fameux phtalates bifteck bisphénol je
savais que j'aurais du mal sur le
bisphénol et les autres à très vite sur
public sénat
il